MANDY WAITE: "I've developed
an application,
[? 12 man months. ?]
But today, I had difficulties
to set up the IT strategy
related to the maintenance
of the source code.
Taking into account the amount
of releases of Google App
Engine Python, do you
have any advice?"
FRED SAUER: OK.
If I remember right, I think
you were sort of suggesting
the person who asked this
question, they asked a few
more questions, and I think you
said it looked like they
were maybe running Python 2.5.
MANDY WAITE: Exactly.
FRED SAUER: Yeah.
So App Engine has a deprecation
policy on all of
our production services.
I believe it's one year.
And that's kind of our guarantee
to you that we're
not just going to change
APIs on you.
That when we bump up the next
version of the application,
your application is going to
continue working, the APIs are
going to behave the way
that they're expected.
Having said that, there
are incremental
changes that we make.
Just like the Python
language is--
Python 2.5 is not as common
anymore as Python 2.7.
At some point you need
to make a switch.
It should certainly not
be a regular burden.
I have applications that I
deployed more than a year ago,
and they're still running
just fine.
That's the experience of
most of our users.
Usually what we find is that
developers are making changes
because they want to take
advantage of new APIs, or new
capabilities, that
we've launched.
There have been probably a
couple of cases where we've
sort of had a changing, not a
breaking API change, but a new
version of a capability that
we've made available, and
that's from Python 2.5 to 2.7
there are some differences.
And Python 2.7 provides a lot of
great features that weren't
possible in 2.5, like
the ability to
handle concurrent requests.
There's many language
preferences.
We also had to change from the
Master/Slave Datastore to the
High Replication Datastore,
which has huge advantages.
The Master/Slave Datastore had
regular maintenance periods.
There's still a few users on
that, but I believe the
majority of users
are now on the
High replication Datastore.
Just a much better experience.
When you commit your data, it
gets committed to multiple
data centers synchronously.
When a data center goes down,
you don't even notice it.
And that sort of improvement
is sometimes worth going
through the effort and making
sure that the way you're
executing queries is
still compatible
with the new version.
But you have plenty of
time to make that
change on your schedule.
So what we find that developers
do, is they sort of
use one version of the SDK,
they're developing locally,
they go through a couple of
releases on their own.
And then there's kind of a
break, maybe once a quarter or
so they say, you know
what, let's catch up
to the latest features.
Let's see what we
can incorporate
that we haven't yet.
And then they'll kind of
bump up the version.
And so you should sort of
naturally flow along with the
App Engine releases.
MANDY WAITE: It's important to
also stress what we mentioned
earlier, experimental features
are always likely to change
from one release to another.
So if you are using an
experimental feature, you'll
probably get enormous benefit
just from using that feature.
But you may have to adjust your
code when we release a
new version, just to keep
up to speed with it.
Hopefully that's not a big
impact, though, not something
that's huge.
FRED SAUER: No, it's generally
a polish around the edges.
When it's in the experimental,
we're still trying to collect
feedback from the community,
find out new use cases, maybe
there's ways that we can improve
the API a little bit.
And so you've seen that, for
example, with the Search API
from the very early
days to now,
there's a couple of changes.
But generally things have just
gotten better and all of our
users have been quite
happy with that.
MANDY WAITE: All right,
excellent.
OK.
So we've got two more
questions here.